two cannonballs of different weights
dropping from the Leaning Tower of Pisa
Galileo's legendary demonstration may be
one of the most famous experiments ever
done
if it was ever done
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
thus it was back in 1589 Galileo
reportedly proved the equivalence
principle the idea that objects of
different weights fall at the same rate
regardless of their Mass
he elaborated on this using a system of
balls and inclined planes which slowed
down the vertical motion to develop his
famous equations about acceleration
predating even the great Isaac Newton
but much doubt remained about how
precise and inviolent this equivalence
principle really is
so the experiment has been repeated and
repeated and repeated in many times in
many places
from the Earth to the Moon the biggest
vacuum chamber in the universe the
universe itself
but science is never satisfied
and that's why the microscope satellite
system took this experiment to the
heights of space itself but before we
can get all the way to outer space let's
go back to the beginning
the basic equivalence principle was
worked out by Galileo and Kepler but it
wasn't until Newton came around a half
century later that an explanation was
found the law of universal gravitation
that is the force due to gravity is
equal to the gravitational constant
capital G times both masses over the
distance between them squared the
inverse Square law
although the force depends on both
masses the acceleration that object 2
feels is independent of the mass of
object two it does look like the second
law doesn't it
it's only dependent on the mass of
object one and its distance from object
one and the gravitational constant
capital G
think of it like trying to pull out a
chair versus trying to pull out a
refrigerator if you want to pull them
out at the same rate the same
acceleration you have to put a lot more
Force onto the refrigerator than onto
the chair the force depends on the mass
but the acceleration is the same
but like I said the law of universal
gravitation like all laws is only an
approximation to reality the only way to
get further trust and approximation is
to get an idea of when it doesn't
predict the things that we do observe in
the universe ever since Newton came up
with the law of universal gravitation he
and other physicists have been laser
focused on testing those limits figuring
out how precise the equivalence
principle and the law of universal
gravitation really are using exotic
materials and exotic locations over the
centuries Newton himself was the first
to try and test the equivalence
principle and find its limits he did
this by getting a bunch of pendula
together of different masses and proving
that they swing back and forth at the
same rate
as a side note this consistency in the
period of any simple pendulum is what
allows grandfather clocks to exist in
all different shapes and sizes
Newton's pendulum experiment allowed him
to narrow down the equivalence principle
down to an accuracy of about one part in
a thousand next up to the gravitational
plate came Frederick Bessel who you
might recognize as the namesake of the
very famous bezel functions so much I
show here
he did the same experiment and
reportedly got the equivalence
principles accuracy down to just one
part in one hundred thousand and then
came the ingenious experiment going from
1885 to 1889 she straight from the mind
of Lauren edwash
it's no surprise that the experiment is
known as the etvash experiment you see
old atvash had the idea of suspending
two masses from one spring attaching a
mirror and Shining a laser to bounce off
the mirror into a telescope this setup
allowed etvosh to see if there was even
a slight impediment to the laws of
universal gravitation now this whole
system is balanced so equally that in an
inertial reference frame it shouldn't
move at all and here's where it gets fun
the Earth is constantly rotating that
means it's constantly accelerating and
if you suspend something from it that it
should feel the effects of that
acceleration too
sort of how like if you make a sharp
turn in a car inertia pushes you in the
opposite direction well if gravity
pulled on these objects by different
amounts it would imbalance the system
changing the inertial acceleration and
allowing you to differentiate changes
from the gravitational acceleration even
if only slightly and it could make the
rod move in a predictable way but it
didn't that Rush repeated its experiment
until the Precision was refined and
published back in 1890.
and those results drum roll please
accurate to one part in a billion from
there and Robert Dickey one of the
pioneers of the cosmicary background
further improved it by another two
orders of magnitude in 1964. in 1971
David Scott dropped an eagle feather and
a hammer on the moon here on Earth the
Feather Falls slower because it's built
like a natural parachute being light
enough to be buffeted by air resistance
on the moon however there is no such
interference and letting the feather and
the hammer hit the ground at exactly the
same time he didn't get a super precise
measurement but it was the most dramatic
measurement ever done to demonstrate the
equivalence principle and billions back
on Earth got to witness this experiment
my girl who made a rather significant
discovery about falling objects in
gravity fields and we thought that uh
where would be a better place to confirm
his findings and on the moon
and so we thought we'd try it here for
you
the feather happens to be appropriately
a falcon feather
for our falcon
and I'll drop the two of them here and
hopefully go hit the ground at the same
time
how about that
more experiments following this would
further narrow down the accuracy of the
equivalence principle up until 1987 when
the ET vosh experiment at University of
Washington conducted an etfosh type
experiment and managed to improve by
another two orders of magnitude to one
part in 10 trillion
and that's where we were for the longest
time decades passed and the principal
didn't get any more love but scientists
have kept on trying in the name of
confirming the equivalence principle or
maybe even finding an aberration a crack
that would allow some light to get
through possibly revealing evidence for
forces and features of gravity that we
had previously not understood what was
the Breakthrough well wasn't a telescope
it's a microscope the microsatellite
with compensated drag for observing the
principle of equivalence the microscope
team has managed to innovate on the
etvosh experiment after it had been the
gold standard for over a century as for
how well it comes down to two things
space and accelerometers but in case
you're wondering what an accelerometer
is it's a device that accurately
measures acceleration they're used in
all sorts of applications for motion
controls and virtual reality to vehicle
stabilization and even gyroscopes that
keep a camera stable they've gotten
better and better and that's what this
study called for two accelerometers as
identical as they could possibly be made
to be using masses suspended within them
from the core of the microscope mission
in a setup called the twin space
accelerometer for gravity experiment
t-sage
was conducted one accelerometer has two
Platinum rhodium alloy masses well the
other one has One Platinum rhodium and
one titanium aluminum magnadium okay
that's right they use different types of
accelerometers they work on the same
principle but they have different
chemistry they have different Atomic
nuclei configurations so we can test if
the acceleration depends on the masses
and the composition of these once and
for all the Alloys are well defined in
terms of their composition and as a
result we have well-defined masses
crucially what this allows the
microscope mission to do is to conduct
their experiments with two materials
with different proton to Neutron ratios
this gives them a lot of fine control
over the gravitational masses of the
samples and that's why this experiment
was able to get the results that it did
but the experiment is also so
susceptible to changes in the heat that
the satellites were bound facing the Sun
for the duration of the experiment to
make sure their temperatures were as
steady as possible the equivalence
principle was tested by microscope to
one part in a quintillion 10 to the
minus 15. the microscope team was able
to push the needle a huge Step Beyond
what had ever been done before imposing
ever tighter restrictions on what
theories could possibly explain
departures from the laws of good old
Isaac
at the moment general relativity Remains
the lead in that department
to learn more about quantum gravity and
its implications click here and don't
forget to subscribe